today's new member of the day is Lane
Esther Lane thank you for being a david
pakman show member really appreciate
your support
you can join Lane at WWE and pac-man
calm coupon code of course available
it'll save you 40% the coupon code is
this is 2020 also want to say thanks
today to George Meyers George Meyers a
friend of mine who has been a member for
almost five years now George thank you
hope to bump into you soon Lane and
George thanks to both of you we are
mostly funded by memberships let's go to
the phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 let's
see let's first go to oh you know who's
on the phone Tim is holding on and last
time Tim called in it was off the rails
and that that intrigues me I'm in an off
the rail sort of mood Tim what's going
on hey how you doing David good hey I
just wanted to get your opinion on the
Democratic Party and to me they seem
very fractured with their ideology and
what they're really trying to you know
run for in terms of presidential runs
the ideals how do you think they're
gonna be 12 but 2020 well there's a
couple different things in there on what
issue do you see the Democratic Party as
being fractured or divided so I see
people like Liz Warren they go really
far less which is a you know a minority
within the party you also have a lot of
centrist that are going in that are you
know talking about you know war and you
know funding these wars and funding
Israel and all these different places
and if they seem to have different
ideologies going in multiple different
directions
okay well it's it's wrong Laurie let's
look hold on let's slow down because
there's a lot there let's really think
it through what would be let's first
start with the first example what's an
Elizabeth Warren far left position
that's out of step with the voters the
green New Deal who are starting on to
that and Medicare for all okay and in
what way are those things out of step
with with the American Left those seem
to be things that the American Left
wants well the American was a lot of
them are centrist so you're talking
about follow up policies like Medicare
for all and the green new deal where
women
don't want to have any more arrows not
medicare-for-all is not far left like
every other country at our level of
development has it no what do you mean
our level of development in what way
you're talking about the Nordic country
no I'm talking about Canada we're
talking about Germany we're talking
about the UK the Nordic countries as
well I mean I don't think to say that
that's an extremist position every
candidate at least has has expressed
some support for medicare-for-all so
that doesn't seem to be something we can
say Elizabeth Warren is doing that's
outside of the mainstream can you think
of any candidate that has straight-up
said they don't want Medicare for all so
far well well let's say on topic I'm
saying Medicare for all let me defend
the reason why I think Medicare for all
is a far less position because no one
has been able to answer specifically how
it's going to be paid for I think what
you're saying is completely untrue
everybody from Bernie Sanders to
economists like Gerald Friedman to even
coke funded think tanks have put out
proposals identifying exactly what it
would cost and how it would be paid for
so that's just wrong but I want to go
back well how is it going to be paid for
you're changing the subject hold on a
second though you brought up how it was
going to be paid for how did I change
the subject no no you're changing the
subject because you're trying to pivot
and not actually answering my question
of how it's going to be paid for you're
just saying who says it's gonna be paid
for and they don't give any answers and
people want affordable care they want to
boil the carrot em Tim Tim let me
understand why you're all over the place
your first assertion which I'm not I'm
on a second hold on your first assertion
which you mentioned is that just in
passing was that Elizabeth Warren is far
to the left of the Democratic Party and
you say I asked for an example and you
cited Medicare for all I agreed upon a
second Tim I pointed out by the way
every candidate so far has also said
they're into the green new deal but
let's just focus on one at a time I was
hilarious but ok but hilarious is
different than untrue right so first you
said it was untrue so let's stay focused
here Tim you said Elizabeth Warren is is
saying things that are to the left of
the Democratic Party you cited Medicare
for all
I pointed out every single candidate on
the left has expressed some degree of
support for Medicare for all you then
brought up that no one has a plan to pay
for it and I told you that actually
there are multiple plans and then you
accused me of changing the subject even
though I was merely following you no no
you I asked how is it going to be paid
for
you still haven't provided the answer
and Adam tim-tim one question at a time
you but you asked most recently how is
it going to be paid for and now I will
tell you after pointing out you've
changed the subject three times it will
be paid for by a 7.5 percent employer
payroll tax after accepting the first 2
million dollars per year of payroll
which saves small businesses from having
to pay that and a 4% tax on the employee
side after the first $29,000 per year of
income that's how it will be paid for
that doesn't make any sense you're
talking about trillions of dollars
that's not enough there it is not enough
Tim I'm gonna let you go cuz I got no
people holding but it's we've looked at
it a whole bunch of times it's it's an
additional 1 trillion a year and we know
exactly how it would be paid for